[MUSIC PLAYING]
HARRIS: Good evening.
My name is Ellen
Harris, and on behalf
of the Office of
the Arts at MIT,
I am happy to welcome
you to the Institute
and to our conference, "The
Public Patron," drafting
a mandate for a
Federal Arts Agency.
The conference is
being presented
by the Office of
the Arts and was
organized by Mark Palmgren,
Director of the Council
for the Arts at MIT.
Before tonight's
program actually begins,
I would like to take this
opportunity to outline briefly
the schedule of events.
First, we hope all
of you here tonight
are planning to attend
tomorrow's panel
discussions, which will also be
held here at Kresge Auditorium,
beginning at 9:15 AM.
In the, morning the panel will
present and discuss issues
relating to the funding
of creative expression.
And then after a
break for lunch,
a second panel will discuss the
role of a Federal Arts Funding
Agency in terms of education
in the arts beginning at 1:30.
Our panel is for
both discussions,
comprising an outstanding roster
of artists, educators, critics,
and arts administrators from
across the country, all of whom
have faced these issues
in their own work.
At 4:15, following the
panels, Representative Louise
Slaughter, Chairman of the
Congressional Arts Caucus,
will present the
concluding keynote
address, after which
she will take questions
from the audience.
Registration for
the day's events,
including lunch, is $35,
$25 for students with ID.
If you haven't
already registered,
I invite you to do so following
this evening's program
or tomorrow morning here at
Kresge, starting at 8:00 AM.
This evening, Charles M.
Vest, President of MIT,
will welcome you, after which
Senator Edward M. Kennedy
and author and art critic Robert
Hughes will present the opening
keynote addresses.
Mr. Hughes has kindly
agreed to accept questions
after his remarks.
If you wish to ask a
question, please step up
to one of the floor microphones
in the two central aisles.
And when you are recognized,
please identify yourself.
I am sure that it will be
appreciated by all of us
if this time is used
for questions only,
and if you will keep
your questions brief
and to the point.
I am pleased to announce that
the Office of the Arts at MIT
will be publishing the
proceedings of the conference.
The proceedings will be
distributed to all conference
registrants, key government
officials, members
and staff of the congressional
committees involved in the NEA
reauthorization and
reappropriation hearings,
and arts organizations
across the country.
MIT will also work
towards developing
an interdisciplinary policy
paper to consider models
for maintaining ongoing
federal support for the arts
and humanities, incorporating
themes and insights
from our deliberations
here this weekend.
And now I am pleased to
introduce to you Charles M.
Vest, President of MIT
[APPLAUSE]
VEST: Thank you
very much, Ellen.
It's a great pleasure
to welcome all of you
to MIT and to this national
conference on the roles
and responsibilities
of a federal art agency
in the United States today.
Some may see MIT, focused as it
is on science and engineering,
as a rather odd choice of
venue for such a conference.
But as most of you
already know, the arts
are indeed a vital aspect of
life here at the Institute.
You need only look around
at our outdoor sculptures,
at our galleries,
and when school
is in session, at the multitude
of courses and programs
and music, theater writing,
photography, dance,
and film that engage our
faculty, our students,
and our staff.
One of the great
things about MIT
is that this is
a hands-on place.
We make things here, and much of
our learning is through doing.
I believe that that is one
of the common denominators
of artistic, technological,
and scientific activity,
and that is one of the reasons
that the arts are indeed
such a vital part
of this institution.
Much of what we
do in these fields
is overseen and coordinated by
our Office for the Arts, which
is sponsoring this conference.
And a great deal of the support
we receive for these programs
comes for the Council
of the Arts at MIT,
the volunteer advocacy
group of alumni, alumnae,
and friends that was
established over 20 years ago
to foster the creative
and performing arts
here at the Institute.
So clearly, the arts are an
integral part of what we are
and what we do.
But why is it important for
scientists and engineers
to study and participate
in the creative arts?
Quite simply, involvement in the
arts broadens one's perspective
and opens the mind
to new possibilities.
The arts spring
from and concentrate
on the human condition,
our history, values,
and cultures, the ways
we find inspiration,
the ways in which we
identify and communicate
ideas and emotions.
And they help us to see
the world in new ways.
It's like looking at
an image upside down
to see it for what it
is and not for what
our eyes are trained to see.
When we develop our ability
to think creatively,
we are able to
find new solutions
to the problems on
which we are working,
both in our laboratories
and in our lives.
Creative activity is
creative activity,
whether it is the
establishment of a new theorem
in abstract mathematics or
the non-obvious optimization
of a complex
engineering process,
or the expression of
an artistic insight.
Education in the arts,
as in the sciences,
helps us to develop and
flex our creative muscle.
It is rigorous exercise.
It is good for us.
One of our professors
who wonderfully embodies
both of these worlds
is Alan Lightman,
a physicist who heads
our program in writing
and humanistic studies.
He's the author of the
widely acclaimed novel
Einstein's Dreams.
And in a recent interview,
Alan explained this duality
of his interests this way.
Human beings have this
very rational, logical need
to order our perception.
But we also need to
take away the fetters
and fly free, escape
from the physical world.
We are both scientists
and artists.
It is a wonderful tension.
We are whole people.
We can't cut off one side
of ourselves from the other.
And I cannot think of a better
explanation for why the arts
are essential to a
complete education, even,
or perhaps I should
say especially,
in a place like MIT.
Science and mathematical
literacy cannot be developed
in the absence of
general literacy.
As Professor Ellen Harris,
MIT'S Associate Provost
for the Arts, who you
just met, has noted,
"The arts offer--"
and I quote her--
"a gateway to improving
learning overall
by enlarging the imagination,
by instilling both discipline
and wonder, and by teaching
flexible and creative
approaches to problem solving."
In short, the
sciences and the arts
do and can inform and
reinforce each other.
So much for the role of
the arts in education
in the place of the
arts at this Institute.
What about the role of
the federal government
as a patron of the arts?
What are the principles
to be followed
and the goals to be achieved?
That is what you are here
to discuss and to debate,
and if the gods are with
us, perhaps even resolve.
For my part, let
me say that when
it comes to the
role of government
in supporting any aspect
of the academic enterprise,
I believe that there is
a fundamental principle.
And that is that the free
investigation of ideas, coupled
with merit review by
knowledgeable experts,
is essential for maintaining
the intellectual and artistic
quality and integrity of work
sponsored by outside agencies,
whether they be the
National Science
Foundation or the National
Endowment for the Arts.
This is a principle that we
have had some trouble sustaining
over the past several
years in our relationship
with the federal government
in many dimensions.
Last year's controversy
over the funding
of the Corporal Politics
Exhibit at the List Center
was but one case in point.
And I do not want to dwell
on that particular event
because it is just a
single example of the need
to renew the partnership
between our universities
and our government, to rebuild
a mutual commitment to investing
in our long-term future
through education, scholarship,
and research.
The time is ripe for rigorous
and high level examination
of the federal
government's complex role
as a patron of the arts.
This conference provides
an excellent opportunity
to work together to
delineate the issues
and articulate our
expectations regarding
the role of creative
expression in our society
and the role of arts in the
education of our young people.
I am delighted that
all of you are here,
and I certainly
look forward eagerly
to the results of
your deliberations.
Now it is my very great
pleasure to introduce our two
distinguished keynote
speakers for the evening.
You will hear first
from Senator Edward M.
Kennedy of
Massachusetts, who for 30
years as a member of the Senate
has played a leading role
in the affairs of our nation.
He has been an eloquent
spokesman for the less
privileged in this country
and for human rights
internationally.
He certainly has been a
strong and effective advocate
for higher education, for
the advancement of research,
and for the financial support
of needy college students.
He is legendary for his tireless
and fruitful work on behalf
of the causes he believes in.
Senator Kennedy has chaired
numerous key Senate committees
and currently is chair of the
Committee on Labor and Human
Resources, which among
its many other duties,
will oversee the
upcoming reauthorization
hearings for the National
Endowment for the Arts.
He will be followed by
Robert Hughes, author and art
critic who reaches 20
million people a week
through his reviews
in Time magazine.
Mr. Hughes is the most widely
read art critic writing today
in the English language.
He is also a
bestselling historian
and one of the most popular
art lecturers in America.
His most recent book,
The Culture of Complaint,
is a critique of American
politics and culture
and has received numerous
enthusiastic reviews.
I'm sure that his
observations this evening
will give us much to think
about and to debate over
the course of this
meeting and beyond.
First, may I introduce
Senator Kennedy.
[APPLAUSE]
KENNEDY: I have to say that's a
little better reception than I
received the other day.
I was down in the southern
part of Virginia speaking,
and someone was introducing me,
and up got some of the people
in the audience and said
that Kennedys a horse's tail.
Words to that effect.
And what happened, some of the
other people at the head table
dragged this person
out of the room.
And I said, well, I didn't know
this was a Kennedy country.
And they said, it isn't.
It's horse country.
[LAUGHING]
I don't want to hear
too much applause.
I want to thank President
Vest for his generous remarks.
And he truly is an
outstanding president
for this outstanding
institution,
and I am honored to
be here with him today
for with this
impressive conference.
And I also want to commend
Ellen Harris, Mark Palmgren,
and the MIT Office of
the Arts for convening
at this timely forum
on public policy
and the federal
role of the arts.
The arts are a central
part of all of our lives,
and support for the arts
is an important principle
of federalism that
I strongly support.
And it's part of our
national responsibility
to encourage a climate
in this country that
promotes development of the arts
and encourages understanding
and participation in
music, in literature,
in painting,
sculpture, and dance,
and many other creative
forms of expression.
MIT is an ideal venue
for this conference.
This incomparable
institution has
produced some of the
finest scientists
and thinkers of our time.
And it is no coincidence
that MIT also
has a longstanding policy
that encourages training
in the arts as a means to
foster creative thinking
and well-rounded
human development.
One of your
distinguished professors
has recently captured
the wonderful blend
of art and science
in an inspired novel,
Einstein's Dream.
It is a warm and
intimate portrait
of that famous scientist,
and I commend him
for his achievement,
Professor Alan Lightman.
It is also a special honor to
share this podium this evening
with another brilliant writer,
who is also a noted critic.
I had the honor of meeting
him last year at the Kennedy
School of Government, and it's
a privilege to be with him now,
Robert Hughes.
As some of you
know, or may know,
I love to paint
with mixed results.
My artist friends
have long advised
me to stick to politics,
and my Republican colleagues
in the Senate are urging me to
switch full-time to painting.
The creative arts represent
our common heritage
and the universal need
for positive expression.
They simultaneously
represent the most personal
of our individual human feelings
and the most universal linking
us to our common humanity.
Some nations and
leaders have attempted
to censor expression they felt
was excessive, or seditious,
or merely inappropriate.
But censorship has never
silenced art for long
in any lab.
And in a congressional hearing
on the National Endowment
for the Arts a few years
ago, the great conductor
Rostropovich spoke
eloquently of the artists
in his Russian homeland,
who lived with censorship
and sometimes lived in exile.
Creative expression
still endured.
The great composers, such as
Shostakovich and Prokofiev,
composed wonderful works.
But as Rostropovich sadly
noted, their fellow citizens
were never permitted
by their government
to share the joy of
these masterpieces.
It is remarkable and instructive
that the leader who guided
Czechoslovakia out of its dark
years of oppression was a great
writer and a visionary,
Václav Havel.
The soul of a nation cannot
be extinguished by any censor.
It is not only foolhardy,
but futile for politicians
to attempt to write
guidelines for acceptable art.
The arts defy orthodoxy or
any other form of mediocrity.
Regrettably, in recent years,
the most public discussion
of the arts in this
country has been
the debate over controversial
works supported by the National
Endowment.
This debate misstates the
mission of the endowment
and insults its proud
record of achievement
over the past quarter century.
It takes a very narrow-minded
critic to see the molehill
and miss the mountain.
The arts endowment does not
belong to any one person
or political party.
It reflects the national
spirit and broad diversity
in our country.
It always has, and
it always should.
But the endowment is
a fragile institution.
It will survive only as
long as the peer panel
system, not political
second guessing system,
determines which applications
for support are funded.
Artistic excellence,
not political passion,
must guide these decisions.
Occasional mistakes should
not become the pretext
for destroying its noble mission
or hamstringing its procedures.
The great irony
of this debate is
that what Senator Jesse Helms
and his indecency brigade
want to do with Soviet
ties American art.
As all of you know,
the List Center
became part of a
national controversy
when an application to
support an MIT exhibition
was rejected by the endowment.
And to your credit and
the endowment's discredit,
the show went on
with private support
replacing the federal
support it deserved.
Incredibly, the acting
chairman of the endowment
subverted her agency's
own procedures.
She ignored the recommendation
of the National Council
on the Arts and the
peer review system,
steps established
by statute to avoid
just this type of
political intrusion
into the endowment's
deliberation.
A national conference like
this is an appropriate forum
to state and restate some
fundamental principles
and avoid a repetition
of distressing incidents
like that.
In a time of other urgent needs
and few resources to meet them,
some conclude that we cannot
afford to support the arts,
but that view is short-sighted.
Federal support for the
arts is an investment
in the future that will
bring important benefits
to the quality of life
in our communities.
A recent national poll found
that fully 92% of Americans
say that the arts are
important to the life
of their neighborhoods.
And they are also important
to their economies.
Ticket sales to
performing arts events
surpass spectator sports by
over a billion dollars in 1989.
In Charleston, South Carolina,
the Spoleto USA Festival
has brought $30 million a year
to the city in the past 10
years.
And in Massachusetts, the impact
has been just as dramatic.
In 1987 and '91, state and
federal funds for the arts
totalled almost
$120 million dollars
and reached over 200
million people and 1 and 1/2
million artists.
Federal support provides
the essential seed money
for broader state and
local private aid.
Nationwide, the federal
investment is less than $0.70
a citizen a year.
Arguably, it's one of
the best investments
the federal government can make.
Our artists are also our most
visible goodwill ambassadors
abroad.
Aaron Copland, Leonard
Bernstein, Agnes de Mille,
and Martha Graham
are quintessentially
American artists, but
their appeal is worldwide.
And so too Ernest Hemingway,
and Emily Dickinson,
and William Faulkner are great
American writers whose words
reach out and touch the world.
The appeal of our artists
was dramatically demonstrated
on inauguration
day last January,
when Maya Angelou recited her
a beautiful poem celebrating
the American national spirit,
and the sense of renewal
that all of us felt that day in
her 1972 autobiography volume,
I Know Why the Caged Bird Sings
returned to the best seller
list and has been
there ever since.
A miracle of marketing?
No.
A miracle of art.
President Kennedy understood
the importance of the arts.
The Center for the
Performing Arts
that bears his
name in Washington
is a fitting living
memorial to his vision.
On its walls are
carved his words,
which symbolize the hope he had
for our country and his belief
that we reach the
highest when we
reach deepest within ourselves.
I am certain that after
the dust of centuries
has passed over
our cities, we too
will be remembered not for our
victories or defeats in battle
or in politics, but
for our contribution
to the human spirit.
The arts chronicle our
history, record our successes,
warn of our weaknesses,
expand our understanding.
They challenge us, not just to
do better, but to do our best.
Federal support to
institutions and individuals
must be accompanied
by accountability
like any other federal program,
but federal support should not
be conditioned or
encumbered by restrictions
that interfere with
artistic freedom
any more than any
federal aid to education
should be used to interfere
with academic freedom.
In testimony before Congress,
constitutional scholar Kathleen
Sullivan warned against content
restrictions on federal aid
to the arts.
We are each masters
in our own homes.
There we may pick and
choose the ideas to which
we open our doors or minds.
But in the government's
house, all ideas are welcome.
Sometimes art shocks
our sensibilities.
It is supposed to.
But that is no justification
for unwarranted intrusions
by extremists who, if
the truth be known,
oppose any federal
aid to the arts.
Obscenity is the place
to draw the line.
Federal dollars
should not be spent
on any project that is obscene.
Current law explicitly prohibits
funding for such projects.
If funds are awarded
for such purposes,
they must be refunded.
The proper way to
determine obscenity
is through the courts.
A new round of contentious
debate about these principles
is on the horizon in Congress.
The Senate must confirm a new
head of the Arts Endowment,
and we must pass new authorizing
legislation for the agency.
Congress will consider
a two-year extension
of the endowment in
the months ahead.
This short-term action will
permit the new administration
to install a new
team at the endowment
and to participate fully
in a comprehensive debate
about these issues.
By any fair accounting,
the endowment
has fulfilled its mission.
It has done an exceptional
job in providing support
to the nation's
cultural institutions,
and it has dramatically
increased the people's access
to the arts.
The challenge for both the
administration and the Congress
is to guide the endowment
beyond the current criticism
and controversy.
The past administration
was willing to be
part of the problem rather
than seek a fair solution.
With the new administration,
we have an excellent chance
to restore confidence
in the agency
and provide a new sense of
purpose for its mission.
Now is not the time, nor I hope
will there ever come a time,
to turn our back on this
essential public commitment
to the arts and free expression.
In closing, let me
say again that it
is an honor to be a
part of this conference.
I look forward to the
results of your deliberation,
and I'm grateful to
you for including me
in this important discussion.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HUGHES: Well, ladies
and gentlemen,
when Mr. Clinton
and the Democrats
came to power in Washington
a few months ago,
there was a good deal
of optimistic talk
among the chattering
classes, to which I belong,
about the end of ideology
in American politics.
After the bruising
divisions of the '80s,
a time of healing
characterized by something
called a search for the center
was supposed to be upon us.
The alternative, which
was set forth in a speech
to the Republican
Convention in Houston
by Pat Buchanan, the
only man of my generation
who ever made me feel however
briefly ashamed to be Irish--
[APPLAUSE]
Well, the alternative was
just too ugly to contemplate.
They have a rhetoric of
revenge, of cultural war.
Remember they're taking
America back street by street
from those who were
not really American,
such as blacks and homosexuals
and liberals and atheists.
Now, Bush that
allowed his program
to be written by the right
wing of his own party,
unfortunately, which
staked everything
upon the idea of a cultural
and religious struggle.
Winning it was going
to return America
to its original virtues, which
had been in steady decline
despite nearly 15 years of
Republican rule since the New
Deal.
And once the Republicans
had lost many liberals
hoped that these specters
of ideological intolerance
would begin to retreat,
baffled and defeated
from the field of culture.
Haven't they tried to fight
an election on cultural issues
and lost?
Wouldn't they conclude from
this that America's overriding
problem might indeed
be the economy, stupid,
and not the issues
so richly symbolized
in the various attacks
upon the National Endowment
for the Arts that were
launched in the late '80s
Well, the short answer is no.
There is no sign of an end
to ideological division
in America, and
still less is there
any sign of healing in the
field of culture and the arts.
In fact, the splits
only seem to get
wider and the shuffle
across them louder.
Jesse Helms and his
ilk spent a few months
licking their wounds,
but now, rest assured,
they are licking their
chops, and they will be
back and with reinforcements.
What happened to the
NEA of the late '80s
was probably only
a prelude to what
is likely to happen in
the immediate future
and a few years down the
road as the millennial year
2000 approaches.
The morals of public
funding is too harsh
and too handy a baton to
remain unprecedented for long.
Now thus far, nobody
has been appointed
as the new director
of the NEA, though we
don't know who
it's likely to be,
nor do I know what the
president's cultural policies
are, in fact, likely to be.
I earnestly pray that
we cannot deduce them
for the inauguration
festivities.
[APPLAUSE]
Stage managed by a couple
of sitcom producers
and stuffed with
Hollywood celebs,
with the sole concession
to high culture
being a poem by Maya
Angelou, on whose merits
I disagree with Senator Kennedy.
The most urgent one, however,
its most urgent priority,
it seems to me, ought to
be defending the endowment.
Well, one of the
most priorities ought
to be defending the endowment
against the pressures of both
the right and the
left in America.
If there was ever a
time when we needed
to think freely and
openly about what
the National Endowment for
the Arts can and can't do,
it is now.
The NEA it is an institution
unique to America.
It is also quite young.
From the Declaration of
Independence until the 1960s,
there had been
absolutely no tradition
of federal support for
the arts in this country,
although there had been
intermittent stabs at it.
And where federal money
and arts policy crossed,
there were usually long delays
and quite a lot of rancor
and a tremendous
amount of log rolling
and the opening of
many pork barrel.
Controversy, for instance,
over the monument
to George Washington in the 19th
century, which took something
like 70 years to
build, was as fierce
as it was over Maya Lin's
Vietnam memorial in the 20th.
Traditional American
laissez faire left no room
for federal arts subsidies.
After all, why should
it in a country
that also rejected such
novelties as public housing
or health care or
unemployment insurance?
City money went to the
construction of civic centers
between 1900 and 1950, and there
were significant tax exemptions
for donors, for concert
halls, for museums,
but active funding of
the arts from Washington
was kept to the
very bare minimum.
As a result, what was
performed, exhibited, and played
in American institutions
between the wars
was largely Europe-dominated
and Europe-driven.
Now as James Heilbrun
and Charles Gray
have pointed out in their
book, The Economics of Art
and Culture, which is due from
Cambridge University Press,
I believe, in August and is
the best introduction that I
know to the labyrinth of the
economics of American culture,
this situation began to change
in the 1950s, when the Ford
Foundation began a program of
grants for American symphony
orchestras.
But the big push for
large scale funding
of the arts from state
and federal governments
started in the early '60s.
At the state level, it began
as many of you will recall,
when Governor Nelson Rockefeller
set up the New York State
Council on the Arts, whose
funding was to peek at in 1976
at $35 million a year.
The idea of the
National Endowment
for the Arts, the NEA,
was proposed in 1961
under John Kennedy
by August Heckscher,
and Lyndon Johnson pushed
it through after Kennedy's
assassination.
The twin sister agencies,
the NEA and the NEH
were written into law in 1965.
And then, as now, these
agencies were strongly
opposed in Congress
by Southern Democrats
and conservative Republicans.
There was in those
days actually a group
of people called
conservative Republicans.
There never has been a
consensus on the need
for national cultural
endowments in America.
And the arguments against
them have scarcely
changed in 50 years.
They lead to government
control of culture,
which tastes of socialism,
or else promotes mediocrity.
They cost too much.
Their worth can't be
shown on a balance sheet.
They reduce the virtues
of private patronage.
More recently-- and this
is argued from controversy
over five or six grunts
among the tens of thousands
made by the NEA in
the last 30 years,
they spread filth
and immorality.
Now, right from
the start, the NEA
was only interested in
fostering the production
of new works of art and in
contemporary institutional
practice.
Methods of historical
preservation,
which are very much to
the fore in the thinking
of cultural agencies
in European countries,
were not within its purview,
as they are, for instance,
within the purview of
the Ministries of Culture
of France, or Germany, or Italy.
The NEA's budget began in
'65 at $10 million a year,
and it reached its peak of
effective spending power, which
was $150 million, in 1979.
And though, the
nominal budget has
gone as high as $180
million in the years
since, when you
figure in inflation,
the present spending power of
the NEA is somewhere around 40%
below its actual
value 15 years ago.
It is about what one
Japanese collector, a forest
tripper called Mr. Saito,
paid for two paintings, a Van
Gogh and a Renoir, just before
the art market crash in 1990.
It is also less per
capita, actually,
than the money given in
cultural support by the States.
Now this, compared
to other countries,
was and is a tiny, a minuscule,
a most parsimonious subsidy.
A study done by Mark Schuster
for the NEA in '85 showed that
America was then giving $3 per
capita to the arts in direct
federal and state owed,
as against $35 in Sweden,
$32 in Canada and France, and
so on down to $9.60 in Margaret
Thatcher's Great Britain.
However, this wasn't
the whole story,
of course, because
none of these countries
gave significant indirect
support to the arts
by allowing business or personal
tax deductions for gifts.
Factor those in, and American
support went up to somewhere
around about $13 per capita,
above Great Britain, certainly,
but still below all the rest.
For there is a further
component, which wholly depends
upon the NEA, which is the
matching grant, by which
the NEA puts it, as it
were, has often been said,
it's a good housekeeping
seal of approval
on a project by
giving half the money,
and thus inducing another
sponsor, corporate one
or whatever, to
pony up the rest.
The NEA is now and
always has functioned
as a vital catalyst for
non-government money
for the arts.
And there seems to me to
be no convincing evidence
that what conservatives claim,
namely that private money would
rush in to fill the gap if the
NEA were to go out of business,
is true or even
remotely probable.
For as a rule, corporate
money likes prestige ventures,
proven successors, wants to
know in advance that it's going
to be a Broadway hit,
whereas it's essential
to the NEA's mandate, as it was
conceived and as I believe it
should continue to go, to
care for what is unproven,
for what cannot yet succeed
necessarily in the marketplace.
You can contrast the position
of the head of the NEA
with that of Monsieur
Jacques Toubon, who
is the new Minister
of Culture in France.
Toubon actually wanted today--
he's a lawyer, and he wanted
the Ministry of Justice,
but his wife has an
interest in the arts,
and so he settled for
the Ministry of Culture,
in which position he
disposes of an annual budget
of approximately $2 billion, 100
times the American equivalent,
with which he can, commission
works of art for the state,
and restore Gothic
churches, and defend
the purity of the French
language, a prospect which
I guess would give
nightmares to anybody
who tried the same thing
in Washington today,
to build opera houses, and
to underwrite the French film
industry with the help
of a tax of 17.5%, which
is applied to every ticket
to an American movie that's
sold in France.
And it is in this way
that Arnold Schwarzenegger
plays for Gerard Depardieu.
[APPLAUSE]
He stands at the top of
a pyramid of interlocking
cultural interest, which
resembles the court of Louis
the 14th, except
that it's much bigger
and has been magnified
over the last 20 years
by the requirements of Francois
Mitterrand and Jack Lang's
Champagne Socialism.
A state-subsidized
composer, official composer,
like Pierre Boulez,
is as a result by far
the most indulged and
politically powerful
man probably in the entire
history of musical politics
in France or anywhere else.
To compare his
influence to that say,
of Philip Glass or the
late John Cage in America
is like comparing
ants and elephants.
As Benjamin Disraeli
observed, if you
want to know what envy is,
you must live among artists.
And if one remembers the
words of a 19th century French
Minister of Culture, who a
night out after a particularly
trying day in the office,
remarked that every time I
award a commission, I create
one ingrate and 30 malcontents.
Such are the joys of
patronage, but what
would make even sponsorship holy
impractical, or particularly
on the NEA's tiny budget, is the
conservative agenda, the agenda
of some conservatives
at least, of prevetting
all grounds for the moral
content of their supposed
results.
Apart from the difficulty--
I mean, as it were, the
existential difficulty
of censoring a work before
it is actually made,
modern democracy, I think,
cannot contemplate without
revulsion the machinery of
supervision that this would
entail.
As a matter of fact, neither
can many conservatives
imagine it, which
is why they say,
you should just
get rid of the NEA.
Better no sponsorship at all
than the risk of blasphemy
or battery on government money.
In fact, many
conservatives seem to me
to be caught in a
sort of contradiction
on cultural subsidies,
half of them saying
that the national endowment
should fold because it's
elitist, and the other half
claiming that in the end,
only high culture
is worth having
and that the NEA should
go because it doesn't
aim high enough.
The taxpayers' money
question is, of course,
an extremely thorny one.
The American right likes
to brandish it as though it
were completely unanswerable.
And the difficulty for
the left and the center
is that they've used it so often
themselves against government
spending that they
don't like, you
know, such as military waste,
if your sense of frugality
is offended by the famous $1,000
ratchet wrench or the $600
toilet seat in a bomber,
why shouldn't someone else
raise a hue and
cry about $40,000
worth of NEA money going
to subsidize a photography
show that includes a picture
of the artist with a bullwhip
up his butt?
Well, it is true
that the money wasn't
very much in the scheme
of American budgets.
It represented about
1/40 of 1% of one copper
penny for every man, and woman,
and child in this democracy.
Nevertheless, as was
frequently pointed out,
it was public
money all the same,
and the point made by Jesse
Helms and Donald Wildmon
and their ilk was that
no sum, however small,
ought to be spent by government
on the dissemination of images
or ideas, that some part
of the taxpaying public
might find morally repulsive.
Therefore, let these
authors do their stuff,
as the saying went, on their
own time and on their own dime,
and never mind that neither
Mapplethorpe nor Serrano
actually received a
cent of government money
themselves from making
their disputed images.
In other words, to qualify
for government support
through the NEA,
a work of art had
to satisfy what
these people imagine
to be a moral consensus.
It had to be, in essence,
incapable of offending anybody,
no matter how low his or
her threshold of offense
might actually be.
Now, the obvious problem is
that in a society containing
something like 260
million people,
there is probably
no such work of art,
not even a nude by
Renoir or a naked baby
Jesus by Andrea Della Robbia.
The insolubility of
the problem appears
if you reflect upon
the amendments which
Jesse Helms and Al
D'Amato and Orrin
Hatch, those Three
Musketeers of Morality,
tried to read into law.
The Helms agreement proposed
that no government funds
should be given by the NEA to
quote "promote, disseminate,
or produce" in its
exact words, "one,
obscene or indecent
materials, including
but not limited to,
depictions of sado-masochism,
homoeroticism, the
exploitation of children,
or individuals
engaged in sex acts,
or two, material which
denigrates the objects
or beliefs of the adherents
of a particular religion
or non-religion,
or three, material
which denigrates, debases,
or reviles a person, group,
or class of citizens on the
basis of race, creed, sex,
handicap, age, or
national origin."
Unquote.
The most obvious and curious
feature of the Helms amendment
was, if it had not issued from
the lips of a famously right
wing Republican senator,
you could have mistaken it--
and especially clauses
two and three--
for any ruling on campus
speech limitations recently
proposed by those other
self-appointed censors who
are cutting loose
in harried society,
those hypocritical
pests of academia
and the politically correct.
It was hard to know
exactly what Helms
meant by a particular
religion or non-religion.
[LAUGHING]
Pantheism.
But certainly,
clause three made it
clear that he was against
racism, sexism, ablism,
lookism, and any of
the other offenses
against social etiquette,
whose proscription by PC
was already causing such
mirth and laughter among older
conservatives
off-campus and creating
not a few new ones on it.
And thus, extremes tend to meet.
In fact, the Helms
agreement was so broadly
drafted as to be
virtually meaningless.
Its effect would
have been to create
a kind of loony parody
of cultural democracy
in which every citizen became
his or her own Cato the Censor.
All the work of art would
need to be defunded,
or if shown in a museum
under NEA auspices,
removed from view, would be to
offend anybody for practically
any reason at all.
The amendment was thus a
sort of crystallization
in very pure form of our present
culture of complaint into law.
It would have made
the National Endowment
hostage to every crank,
ideologue, and God botherer
in America.
A grounds for the exhibition
of, say, Gothic Ivories
could be pulled on the
grounds that the material was
objectionable to Jews,
since much medieval art is
deeply anti-Semitic, or to
Muslims, because who know?
One of those ivories might have
contained a not uncommon figure
of false prophets boiling
in hell with Muhammad, which
was quite a favorite
in the Middle Ages,
or for that matter,
to atheists offended
by the use of government
money to insert
any sort of
religious propaganda,
including ancient ivory
carvings into a museum.
And indeed, one could imagine
some Stalinist feminist
complaining that a 13th century
depiction of a patriarchal god,
or the sexism implicit in a
subservient or tempting Eve,
was repugnant to her
religion or non-religion.
[APPLAUSE]
Under the Helms amendment,
a fire worshipper
might well claim that the
presence of extinguishers
in the museum was
repulsive to his deity.
[LAUGHING]
Now Helms and his
supporters were, of course,
at pains to deny that the
amendment had anything
at all to do with censorship.
Nevertheless, one
would have needed
to be remarkably naive to
suppose that censorship was not
the root of this controversy.
The efforts to cut
off government money
from offensive art were but the
tip of a general effort growing
on the right to repress
all offensive art,
subsidized or not, under
the assumption basically
of their proponents that the
stuff isn't a necessary part
of social discourse anyway.
The wisest analysis
of this problem
was offered some months
later by a Jesuit,
rather the Reverend Timothy
Healy, the Director of the New
York Public Library,
now alas dead.
The debate is about
censorship, Father Healy
declared to a house subcommittee
post-secondary education
in November 1989.
And he went on,
"Against the argument
that the artist was free to
write, to paint, or to compose
as he pleases without
federal subsidy,
we must urge that to deprive an
artist of that subsidy because
of the content of his work
is a clear and strong kind
of censorship.
The counter-argument
is really a dodge.
The mixing up of the realm of
law with the realm of morals
is deadly.
Law can tolerate evils
that morality condemns.
We have a good law if it can be
obeyed, if it is enforceable,
and if it is so
prudently drafted
that it avoids most of
the harmful effects that
flow from it.
If a law does none
of these things,
it is a bad law, no
matter what the logic
or the moral
intensity behind it."
Unquote.
Though none of the
arguments heard
on the Senate floor attained
the clarity and sophistication
of this priest's words, the
Helms amendment was voted down.
But its defeat did
not dispel the idea
that the US
government implicitly
puts its moral weight
behind all the art
that it funds, that the artist
with an NEA grant becomes,
as it were, the
voice of the state,
and that the state is therefore
to be held responsible for what
he or she makes or says.
The NEA, however, it
was never conceived
as an arm of state propaganda,
except in the very general
sense that Kennedy,
Johnson, and their advisors
felt that America should
support its own artists
and would, in some general
way, look better for doing so.
There is a huge difference
between commissioning a work
of art and sponsoring a talent.
The patron says, when he
is commissioning something,
I want a mural with me on
horseback showing democracy
trampling on ignorance.
And moreover after that,
I want to own the mural.
The NEA essentially puts a
bet on talent at arm's length
through the peer review
system, and then it
gets out of the way.
Once you forget the difference
between state commissioning
and this kind of sponsorship,
every attack upon the NEA
becomes possible.
I mean, this was the confusion
behind the culture war's
equivalent of the
Willie Horton ad.
Pat Buchanan was noted a TV
spot attacking George Bush
through the NEA and PBS.
Many of you must have seen
this when you saw clips
from a documentary that had
been made for PBS about gays.
The clips with leather queens,
capering in the street,
and of course, of the March.
And over this
appalling Saturnalia,
their came the voice
of a narrator saying
that this is what George
Bush was investing your tax
dollars in.
Note the use of the verb.
Investing in half-naked
gays, the way
that his father used
to invest in oil money.
Here was Bush putting
your money into a kind
of wildcat scheme for the
propagation of homosexuality.
But actually, that
isn't the way it works.
The idea behind the
NEA fundamentally
is that a democracy can
subsidize a forum, an agora,
a marketplace of
ideas and images,
without specifying in advance
what kind of images and ideas
should be displayed in it.
This certainly relies upon
some kind of an agreement.
Some kind of an agreement
of common interest
between the sponsor
and the artist.
But there are plenty
of precedents for it,
and there are plenty
of working parallels
to it in American life already.
When, for instance, a
university gets federal, state,
or city funds, they
come with the assumption
that the place will remain
free from ideological pressure,
and that any issue can be
reasonably exposed and debated
on campus.
If this isn't so, the
university, state-subsidized,
wholly or partially, cannot
function as a place of teaching
and learning.
The fact that public
money is involved
does not mean that the
university should avoid,
or skirt controversial
ideas, or punish people
for uttering them.
The university has
to stick to that,
no matter how
inconvenient it may be,
and it sometimes is
extremely inconvenient.
For example, I and
many other people
regard Leonard Jeffries
as an anti-Semitic madman,
whose scholarship is farcical.
But you cannot get rid of him
now by saying that the views
that he teaches are
offensive to most Americans,
blacks included, and that
since CCNY gets dollars from
the taxpayer, he should for
that reason be forced out.
On an even more basic
level, the city,
like any other in America, has
parks and squares and streets
which are maintained
by public funds.
And yet, it is perfectly legal
to express your views in them,
however repugnant those
views may be to others.
That is a basic part
of citizens' rights
under the First Amendment.
If I want to demonstrate
for or against abortion
in that state-sponsored
civic space, I can.
If I want to propose
voting rights for insects
or urge the immediate
repatriation of all Catholics
from Boston to Ireland,
I can do that too.
I may not succeed,
but I can do it.
The assumption behind
this and behind the NEA
too is that the diversity
in a democracy is good.
We agree to pool our
tax dollars to create
a general frame in which
opinions can be freely uttered
and images freely propagated.
Any opinions, however much
they may annoy or offend
somebody else who
also has the right
to express his or her
opinions, no matter
repugnant I might find them.
Does this mean that the
NEA is obliged to subsidize
any and every kind
of utterance without
a static moral, or political,
or other distinctions,
or considerations?
I don't believe so.
No sponsor, still less
patron, in the history of art
has ever done this.
But it does mean
that the NEA has
to be prepared to resist
unreasonable pressure,
not only from the
moralists and censors
of the fundamentalist right,
with their cant about family
values, but also from
the censorious left,
with its consistent betrayal
of the liberal ideal
that high cultural
standards can be popularly
accepted and practiced.
It has got to shift
its attention away
from the cliches of our time,
the chatter about empowerment,
the obsession with resentment
as a cultural standard.
There is a right tool of
device, and there is a left one,
and between the two, the
NEA is painfully squeezed
and may, in the end, be
distorted out of useful shape.
These pressures
are or the outcome
both of the PC belief that the
personal is the political, acts
of imagination not exempted,
and of the conservative view,
that any stick you can beat
liberals with is a good stick,
and never mind what else gets
flattened in the struggle.
The National
Endowment for the Arts
was not, in fact, designed to
be an arena for such disputes,
and thus it proved
extraordinarily awkward
and even inept at
responding to them.
And its response is complicated
by the claims of activist art
to constitute an avant garde.
The population of the art
world expanded enormously
in the 1980s.
And in an overpopulated art
world with a depressed market,
you are going to hear more
and more about discrimination
against artists, endless
complaints about racism,
sexism, and so on, whereas the
fundamental underlying problem
is that there are too many
artists of all kinds in America
for the base of collectors
and sponsors to support.
That is why the National
Endowment for the Arts really
matters in the ecology
of American culture,
but it cannot do good
work, in my opinion,
if it caves in to the forced
politics of group entitlement.
The sense of disenfranchisement
among artists
has led to a stream of attacks
upon the idea of quality,
as though it were
the enemy of justice.
Quality, the argument
goes, is a plot.
It is the result of a
conspiracy to marginalize
the work of other
races, other cultures,
by the patriarchal penis people.
And to invoke its
presence in works of art
is somehow inherently
repressive.
This drivel has become
the new orthodoxy,
and fewer and fewer
critics and historians
seem able to resist it.
More and more, it is assumed
that one's cultural reach
is fixed and determined
forever by whatever
slot one is raised in.
You can imagine the
contempt with which
a great Mexican artist
like Diego Rivera
would have reacted to this.
Rivera probably
gave more to Mexico
in terms of self-knowledge
and cultural pride
than any artist whose name we
know in its entire history,
but he was only able to do
so because he had absorbed
and completely internalized the
great tradition of Renaissance
Fresco painting, which
combined with his absorption
in French modernism,
pre-Colombian Mexican art,
and living folk art to produce
the tremendous results that we
see on such walls as those
of Palacio Nacional in Mexico
City.
If you had told Rivera
that quality didn't matter,
he would have
laughed in your face.
Now you can't deny that at any
time in the history of art,
there have been
inflated reputations
and wrongly ignored artists.
Certainly, this is as
true today as it ever was.
This happens in the short-term,
but in the long run,
the injustices do
tend to be corrected.
There remains, for
instance, practically
no institutional bias against
women artists in America
any more than there is
a bias against women
writers in American publishing.
And this is certainly very
different to the America
that I first came to in 1970.
And yet, you have to bear in
mind that not all artists are
wrongly ignored.
[LAUGHING]
Mediocrity is the natural fate
of most creative endeavor,
especially in a society, which
in the name of therapeutics
and personal growth, has
removed most of the rigor
from the training
of its artists.
[APPLAUSE]
Most art made by white
Americans is mediocre.
Most made by black
Most art made by Chinese
Americans, Japanese Americans,
and American Indians
is mediocre too.
And most art made by
women is as mediocre
as most art made by men.
The same applies to
gays and straights
and to all the other polarities.
We must therefore be extremely
wary of the sentimentality
that institutional
multi-culti breeds.
Those who talk about
remedial multiculturalism
as a radical program--
and as anybody who has
read my book will know,
I am very much a friend
of multiculturalism,
and I am totally in favor of it.
Otherwise, I would never
have left my own country
to begin with in
order to start trying
to see through the
scrims that divide us
and understand other
peoples image banks.
But this is not what is meant
so often by multiculturalism
in this society.
What is meant so often
is a sort of separatism.
Anyway, those who talk
about remedial multi-culti
as a radical program fail
to see how conventionalizing
and soothing and altogether
consoling to middlebrow
taste its effects
can tend to be.
One already sees this
in one area, that
of publicly funded artware.
Multicultural programs serve
to get the embattled National
Endowment for the Arts
off the hook of making
any discriminations at all.
If the Philistines
are begging for an end
to government
support for high art,
for difficult and possibly
controversial art,
and if meanwhile the
moralists are yelling
for the blood of any poet or
performer whose work might
raise hackles in some
golf club in Tulsa,
then what could be a better
refuge than multiculturalism.
Just turn the already meager
trickle of government money
towards stuff that nobody
could quarrel with,
areas such as-- to point
from a recent brochure,
issued by the NEA's last
director, Anne-Imelda Radice--
quote, "Hmong needlework,
coastal sea grass basketry,
Southeast Alaskan native
dance, American Indian basketry
and woodcraft, Pacific
island canoe building,
and Appalachian banjo playing."
this sentimental form
of cultural diversity as
interpreted by federal funding
agencies and an increasing
number of private
foundations may or may not
pick some good stuff
out of the woodpile.
But most of the time,
entails pious gestures
of cultural support while
actually producing remarkably
little that would,
in aesthetic terms,
challenge, refine,
criticize, or in any way
extend the thinking
of the status quo.
Under the rubric of
self-esteem, they
foster mediocre for a populist
mentality that contents itself
with relatively
easy tasks expressed
in the jargon of supporting
ethnicity and gender
differences in the arts, instead
of the harder one of looking
for real excellence.
Too much of the art that
results from such programs
turns out to be
affirmative prolix kitsch,
gushing with sincerity,
and people like it
for the same reasons
that they like
Hallmark Cards
with sumi-e herons
and New Age verses on them.
It just makes them feel good.
[LAUGHING]
Now you can certainly run a
feel-good cultural program
on sociological and
statistical criteria,
backing it up with the usual
pieties about empowerment.
And this conforms very well
to the evangelical tradition
of American cultural life,
the idea that one is morally
improved, uplifted, and
turned into a better citizen
by producing or consuming art.
But the art that it fosters
maybe, and sometimes
is, quite banal.
What happens where
government arts
money and populist
multiculturalism intersect?
All too often a form
of moral blackmail,
with one eye on the pork barrel.
Now in Holland for
the last 20 years,
they tried a form of popular
support for everybody.
The government set up a fund to
buy work by artists no matter
how good it was.
All that mattered was
that the artist should
be A, alive, and B, Dutch.
About 8,000 Dutch artists are
represented in that collection.
None of it is shown.
And as everybody in
Holland, including
most of the artists involved, I
feel now admits about 98% of it
is rubbish.
The storage expenses
are so high that they
have to get rid of the stuff.
But they can't because
nobody wants it.
They tried giving it
to public institutions,
like lunatic asylum
and hospitals.
[LAUGHING]
But even the lunatic asylums
insisted upon standards.
They wanted to pick and choose.
So there it all sits.
Democratic, non-hierarchical,
non-elitist, nonsexist,
unsalable, and to
the great regret
of the Dutch authorities,
only partially biodegradable.
[LAUGHING]
Now there are lessons from this,
and let me suggest two of them.
The first is that if Dutch
madhouses can discriminate
about art without being accused
of anti-democratic elitism,
so can the NEA.
But mind you, I speak as
an unrepentant elitist.
I don't think democracy
is any guide to taste.
I think the job of democracy
in the field of art
is to make the world
safe for elitism.
[LAUGHING]
[APPLAUSE]
Not an elitism based upon race,
or money, or social position,
but on skill and imagination.
And the embodiment of high
ability and intense vision
is basically the only thing
that does make art popular.
It is why the Rijksmuseum
is full of people
and the remedial art basements
of Amsterdam are not.
The greatest popular
spectacles in America elitist
to the core--
football games, basketball
games, professional tennis.
But nobody is going to
pay to watch Hilton Kramer
and me swim the 800 meter
freestyle in 35 minutes
flat despite our relatively
privileged position
as white European males.
Like sport, art is
an area in which
elitism can display itself at a
negligible cost in social harm.
The second lesson is that if
a scrupulous participatory
democracy like Holland spends 25
times per taxpayer what America
does on culture, choosing
art on sociological grounds
in the name of complete
cultural egalitarian
and then ends up with a
garbage disposal problem,
what guarantee is there that
we can do much better here?
Absolutely no guarantee
that I can see.
It is in the nature of human
beings to discriminate.
We make choices and
judgments every day.
These choices are part
of real experience.
They are influenced
by others, of course,
but they are not
fundamentally the result
of a passive reaction
to authority.
And we know, I think, that
one of the realist experiences
in cultural life is that
of a certain inequality
between books, and musical
performances, and paintings,
and other works of art.
Some things do strike us
as better than others.
Aesthetically better.
More articulate.
More radiant with consciousness.
We may have
difficulty saying why,
but the experience remains.
An aesthetic
discrimination must not
be tarred with the brush
of racial or gender
discrimination.
It corresponds to
experience, just
as our perception and
comparison of grace
in the work of a basketball
player or a tennis pro
rises from experience.
And these differences of
intensity and meaning and grace
can't be set forth in a little
catechism or a recipe book.
They can only be experienced,
and argued, and then
seen in relation to a
history that, of course, must
include social history.
Now the NEA, as I understand
it, was founded in order
to identify, to pick
out, those sparks
in the cultural campfire
around which we all
sit, wherever they may
be found, to fan them,
to give them oxygen, to
bring them into flame.
This is the way that sponsorship
makes its modest bets
about the future.
The moment you go
to other criteria,
you may be in trouble.
If you reform your
program in terms
of agendas based on the artist's
race or gender or supposed
degree of cultural
enfranchisement, if you start
agonizing, for instance, about
whether the quota of grants
to Hispanic activist video
artists has being fulfilled,
you will have no answer
to the conservatives who
then turn around and want to
know why the NEA isn't giving
equal grants to Christian
fundamentalist poster
designers.
I am certainly an
elitist in that
I believe in high
aesthetic standards,
and I think the NEA should too.
I'm also a populist
in that I believe
that these standards
can and do make sense
to people who are prepared
to pay enough attention.
The surest way to convert
the NEA into a dead letter
is to make its sponsorship an
area for battles, many of which
do indeed need to be
fought, but fought
in the sphere of politics.
The trouble with fighting
political battles
on cultural turf is twofold.
First, as many of us will
recall from the 1960s,
they are rarely won there.
And secondly, in
the process, you
may simply kill the grass
so that everybody loses.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
HARRIS: Are there any questions?
[LAUGHING]
Yes, please come down to the
microphone so we can hear you.
Tell us who you are.
AUDIENCE: My name is Williams,
and I live here in Cambridge.
Two questions in
response to your talk.
One is, you got into a bit
about the question of elitism.
In discussion here
tonight with someone
who I consider to be
a very good artist,
he described the Boston
Symphony as basically preserving
music that was once
performed for kings
for today's equivalent,
only it's subsidized by--
there's a subsidy for
the wealthy people
primarily so they can
go and enjoy this music.
And so I wonder if
you could speak to
not whether it is
good or worthy,
but whether it
should be subsidized.
Maybe it should be paid for by
the people who are enjoying it.
HUGHES: Who supposes that the
audience at the Boston Symph
would consist exclusively
of the wealthy?
AUDIENCE: Right.
No, I understand.
I don't think it is-- actually
they do have $6 rush tickets,
and that was part of--
HUGHES: Yes, well,
it doesn't seem to me
that you need to be an unusually
wealthy person to afford
a ticket to the Boston Symph.
I would have thought that your
acquaintance could have better
phrased it by saying that
they were taking music which,
some of which at
any rate-- you know,
it's not true that all the
music that the Boston Symphony
performs or any other
symphony performs
was actually written
at the behest of kings.
But some of which, let's say,
for the sake of argument,
was performed by kings,
and recycling it back
to people who were not kings.
In other words,
recycling it back
to the citizens of the
democracy, rich and poor.
I mean, it seems
to me profoundly
condescending to suppose
that the only people who
are interested in what
is, for convenience,
called high culture
are the rich.
It is not true.
And if it were
true, every musical,
every symphony hall in America
would have closed long ago.
If classical music didn't have
some kind of popular base,
it couldn't survive.
AUDIENCE: The other question
I wanted to ask about
was, in my experience
in Cambridge
with Cambridge as
an Arts Council,
this was another criticism
that was levied against--
well, the problems of
funding of the arts
is that the sense that,
at least on a local level,
maybe not as much
on a national level,
that it becomes a kind
of arts bureaucracy
where arts bureaucrats,
not artists,
who have a regular
staple of favorites
that they fund year after
year who aren't, in fact,
excellent--
HUGHES: Well, I think there's
probably a good deal of merit
to that criticism.
There is always-- one of the
great problems of setting up
arts founding systems is to
avoid losses by log rolling,
by favoritism, by
backscratching,
and simply by
bureaucratic friction.
And I think one of the inherent
problems of the NEA peer review
system is that you get chaps
and chapesses scratching
one another's back.
But when you think
of the alternative
to it, all the various
alternatives to it,
I think probably there
is still quite a lot
to be said for the
peer review system.
But the idea that--
alas, we do not live
in a Utopian world.
And it has never been
possible to devise--
I think probably
not since the time
that Aug and Maug first
did their first buffalo
on the Orignation Caves.
It has not been possible to
devise a system of arts funding
that totally eliminated
favoritism and log rolling.
Alas.
But the question
is, because of that,
because arts funding
does not represent
the sort of mechanisms of
an ideal cultural world,
do you therefore
dispensing with it?
I mean, I shudder to think of
the number of really rather
mediocre works of art that
have been commissioned
in France in the 19th century.
Quite a few.
And endless protests from
artists and complaints
from artists about the laxity,
the blindness, the deafness,
the general unresponsiveness
of cultural bureaucrats.
I mean, you read the
journals of Hector Berlioz,
for instance, one sees
it at full stretch.
Nevertheless, on
the ballots, I think
one is grateful in the end that
there was some kind of system
set up for the public
encouragement of the arts,
on the results.
AUDIENCE: I wondered
what your thoughts
were about the idea of
artists suing the NEA.
This happened recently.
A number of artists
and performers--
HUGHES: Well, it's America.
Everybody sues everybody else.
This is the most litigious
society that ever existed,
I think.
I have to tell you
quite honestly,
I haven't closely
followed the ins and outs
of the case that was
brought, I think,
by Karen Finley,
and Holly Hughes,
and others against the NEA.
I mean, my first reaction
was, oh, come on.
Give me a break.
But it revolves
around the question
of whether active censorship
did indeed take place,
and I think the court
concluded that it did so.
But I'm afraid that I haven't--
rather to my shame, I
have not followed that.
I've not given
that the attention
that I should have because
I was working on a book.
And so consequently, I'm
sorry to cop out like this.
I really do feel that it is
hard to talk about people's
entitlements to a grant.
Nobody is entitled to
a government grant.
I think this is a spin-off
from an excessive kind
of caricatured
sense of entitlement
that runs through
America at the moment.
HARRIS: Could you
tell us who you are?
AUDIENCE: My name is
Larry [INAUDIBLE]..
I'm from Prague.
HARRIS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My name
is Liam Rector.
I'm covering this for
The Harvard Review,
and I teach at
Bennington College.
I understood you,
Mr. Hughes, that you
must have read John
Frohnmayer's book,
Getting Out of Time Alive?
HUGHES: Yes, I did.
AUDIENCE: It's, in my
view, a pitiful book.
HUGHES: Yes, in my view too.
AUDIENCE: I'd like
to know thoughts
on the book itself, one.
And two, I'd like
to know what sort
do you think would be a good
NEA director, both in general,
and some specific examples
you have might have--
HUGHES: Oh, well--
AUDIENCE: --of somebody
that would lead the NEA,
for example.
HUGHES: --obviously,
you need a woman
with the reach of a gorilla and
the balls of a brass kangaroo.
[LAUGHING]
Frohnmayer fulfilled none
of these requirements.
I mean, Frohnmayer
is a very nice bloke.
He hasn't got a mean
bone in his body.
That's why his tenure
at the NEA was such a--
was so bedeviled.
In order to resist the kind
of political opportunism
that is thumping upon the--
I mean, you know, there are
various grounds for criticizing
the NEA, which range
from, shall we say,
at least an intelligent
conservative view
of the matter to this kind
of lumping opportunism,
which we see from the
right Republicans.
They're just basically
grandstanding
and don't give a damn about
what the cultural health
of this country might
or might not be.
And in order to resist this, one
needs an extraordinary amount--
you just need to
be extremely tough.
Frohnmayer wasn't
tough, nor do I
believe that he had his
fundamental cultural priorities
in the right place.
He came into there
not quite knowing
what he thought, brandishing
his little cello,
or whatever the hell
it was he plays.
No, there are little cellos.
I'm sorry.
And he was like a
fish out of water.
And the subtitle of his book--
what was it?
Memoirs or Confessions of
an Arts Warrior, you know,
which suggests some
brave fellow going
forth with his magic
sword to conquer
the Mordor of Washington.
Well, of course, it's hokum.
He was the wrong guy
in the wrong place,
just as I would say Anne-Imela
Radice was the wrong person
in the wrong place.
And anybody who
goes into running
the NEA on the terms which
were dictated for Radice
is also going to be the wrong
person in the wrong place.
Because if you have a
supposedly independent system
of arts funding, which then
becomes buffeted around
on the whims of whatever
the electoral requirements
of the moment might
be, as the NEA was
during Frohnmayer's and
Radice's tenure, then
the institution is not
well-served by those
who run it.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: This gentlemen.
HUGHES: Oh, I'm sorry.
Here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Sam Walker, and I'm
with The Christian Science
Monitor.
And my question is, in an
age of extreme pressure
to reduce government spending,
what would your strongest
argument be to the
appropriations committee
to either maintain or
increase funding for the NEA?
HUGHES: I think
it would be rather
difficult to make the argument
for increasing its funding
to fly.
Although, I do actually believe
that the NEA would probably not
even do better if it had
more money at its disposal.
The argument that I would make
is a very straightforward one.
Really, it is that some
degree of government
support for works of
art, be they concerts,
or theater, or
whatever, performance
of any kind, or
paintings, or sculpture,
is actually necessary
in a society
where not everything
that is good
can depend automatically
upon private or corporate
institutional support.
The second argument is that
the main function of the NEA,
as I see it, is to
act as a catalyst
towards institutional
support for genuinely
informative and useful
kinds of cultural--
I hate the word
cultural programming,
which sounds stern.
You know, cultural events.
You know, the
sustenance of museums,
the sustenance of
symphony orchestras
and so forth, which actually,
after the over optimistic
projections made in the '80s
about how everything could be
take, or all this
kind of support
could be taken up by
the private sector,
it has been fairly well
shown that, actually, it's
not so easy for the private
sector to come in fearlessly
and do it.
It needs a certain
amount of encouragement.
It needs to be led by the nose.
The NEA has always had a
very important function
in this relationship.
I defend the NEA primarily
as catalyst and only
in the second place as patron.
And I would say to
people who are calling
for a diminishment of its funds
that these funds are already
cut to the bone.
They are by comparison to
other great democratic states
in Europe almost
ludicrously low,
and that their present
expenditure does not
involve any serious drainage
from other vital parts
of national interest.
So why not keep it going?
AUDIENCE: If I could follow up.
There have been some arguments
that in order to be a catalyst,
the NEA doesn't necessarily
have to send any money in,
that the stamp of
approval from the NEA
doesn't necessarily
constitute spending.
How would you respond to that?
HUGHES: Oh, I think there's
no sign of commitment
quite like a check.
[LAUGHING]
Words is cheap.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: My name is Roger Kahn.
I'm a professor, and I'm
the Director for the Center
for Non-Profit
Organization of Leadership
at Regis University in Denver
and the program chairman
of a forthcoming conference
on arts, culture,
and community public funding
and social responsibility.
Your comments on the Dutch
experience and your observation
that the goal of the
democracy of the arts
is to make the world
safe from elitism
made me wonder what
you, in fact, think
whether the NEA and other
public funding sources
are suitable criteria for
supporting public arts.
HUGHES: Whether I think
they have suitable criteria
or they do have criteria?
AUDIENCE: Not whether
you do think they have,
but what you think
they might be.
HUGHES: One is often asked about
what criteria should be assumed
by the NEA as if there were a
kind of a yardstick which that
august institution could put out
of its pocket and lay alongside
a work of art.
Basically, what the NEA does,
and what I think it should do,
is make the kind of educated
guesses about sensibility
and its action about
creative sensibility
that you or I might make as
sort of literate observers
of whatever art we like,
and then go ahead and do it
on that basis.
In other words, I tried
earlier in the speech
to outline very strongly, you
know, to argue very strongly,
that in the first
place, the NEA should
be looking for some sort
of genuine and arguable
excellence, hopefully in the
results that it subsidizes.
But that excellence
could only be
argued in the presence
of the work of art.
This is one of the big
problems with funding things
before they actually take place.
You see the results afterwards.
And it may work or not.
But basically, what
they should be doing
is looking for serious
talent within the field
that they wish to
subsidize and going
on whatever aesthetic criteria
they believe to be proper
and which can be argued.
And I believe they
should be argued.
AUDIENCE: If I can push
that for just one second,
it seems to me that if
Picasso was incarnated,
we might find that he
would worthy of support
because of his prior record.
HUGHES: Yes, we know
that he's Picasso.
AUDIENCE: I listen to
what you're saying.
And in the context of the
pluralistic democracy, where
there are so many people
that we are not familiar,
and so many groups with
which we are not familiar,
are there any standards
that you can think of
or criteria that
you can articulate
that would help us deliver
the process of figuring out
what it is we want to be
supporting of with money.
HUGHES: You go for
the work of art.
You go for the person or
the group's past record.
You look as
attentively as you can
at what that person
or group has done.
You try to figure
out, therefore,
you know, on that basis
whether that talent
has the kind of coherence and
adventurousness spirit and sort
of intelligence of
results that one is
looking for in a work of art.
As I say, it is hard to sort
of invent a verbal three foot
rule, which you can then lay
alongside a play or a painting
in advance and say, OK,
this measures up to it.
This doesn't.
One's understanding
of a work of art
is essentially an
existential matter.
It happens in the
presence of the work.
You get some sort of
a visceral reaction.
And it's that, you know?
It's the ability of the
thing to, I suppose,
spark that promotes the small
act of faith in the artist.
In other words, it is
a subjective judgment.
You cannot escape subjective
judgments by multiplying
subjectivities in the
form of a committee.
It still ends up as a
subjective judgment,
and it has to be
pursued as such.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Since you talked
about multiculturalism--
Patty Martin with
The Boston Globe.
HUGHES: How do you do?
AUDIENCE: --say that
issues of multiculturalism
should not be played
out in the National
Endowment for the Arts?
HUGHES: No, I didn't say
issues of multiculturalism
shouldn't be.
I said issues of group
entitlement shouldn't be.
There's a very
important distinction.
AUDIENCE: Well,
then, I'm curious,
what do you think
cultural institutions
should be doing about this?
HUGHES: They should
be encouraging talent.
AUDIENCE: Even with demographics
that we don't know about?
HUGHES: They should
be encouraging talent,
and talent it is not necessarily
a function of demographics.
They should be looking as
widely as they possibly
can across the
demographic spectrum.
That goes without saying.
But in the last
analysis, when it
comes down to what
you're going to fund,
you're funded on the
basis of what you think
is good, the work I meant.
They shouldn't be having
quotas for blacks or gays
or women or whites or whatever.
There should be no such
quotas in my opinion.
No.
But there should be a
very definite openness
to all those groups and
to all sectors of society,
and there should be
a profound curiosity
about what they're doing.
And then at the end
of the day, you've
still got to make your judgment
on the basis of whether you
think there's real
talent there or not.
AUDIENCE: This
gentlemen, I think,
was trying to get at
questions of standards.
Do you think standards differ
from committee to committee?
I mean, one might wanna look
at ancient period itself--
HUGHES: Well, it depends on
what you mean by standards.
If, as many people
think, you know,
there are hermetically
sealed different standards
from community to
community, why is it
that you or I could
go into a museum
and look at a work of art
from a culture immensely
separated from us in space and
time and cultural assumptions,
such as, for instance, a bronze
pot from the Chu dynasty,
and find it absolutely radiant
with meaning and beauty?
My view is that the idea of
differing aesthetic standards
from community to
community is one
which has been tremendously
inflated in America
and rather badly argued.
In point of fact, there is
absolutely no reason on Earth
that I can think of why,
for instance, a white reader
wouldn't be able to get the
point of reading Langston
Hughes, or why a black
onlooker wouldn't
be able to get into the work
of Piero della Francesco
just as much as a white one.
I think there is far too--
I think there is a
great deal of can't
involved in the inflation
of the idea of differing
aesthetic community standards
on aesthetics within America.
But my point is, and
I've made it before,
and I will make it again.
It is absolutely essential
that funding bodies
should look and pursue
their investigation of what
is out there as
widely as possible.
There must be no
group, no person,
who is ineligible a priori
for this kind of support.
AUDIENCE: Should the
bodies be represented?
HUGHES: Well, I think
they already are.
And yes, I think they should be.
Yes.
But again, I think it
is rather difficult
to formulate recipes for this.
You know, obviously, you don't
want monochrome or monosexual
bodies determining this.
You know, of course.
I mean, it's a democracy.
It should run
across the spectrum.
But on the other hand, since
Americans at the moment
are so fond of
dividing themselves
into microconstituencies
and then claiming
that each of these
microconstituencies
represents a separate
culture, which very often
they really don't,
there is a severe danger
that that whole process can
bog down and become just
vociferous and meaningless.
But in the broader
spectrum, yes, I
think it would be
ridiculous, for instance,
to have some kind
of a requirement
that each review
panel should contain
70 gays and 70 straights.
But on the much larger
divisions-- men,
women, blacks, whites,
Hispanics, whatever-- yes,
I think there's a very strong
case to be made for that.
And in practice, it
works out that way.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Caroline
[INAUDIBLE] from New York.
Do you believe that
there should be
a cabinet or at most a minister
of culture in the United
States?
HUGHES: No, I do not.
No.
I think it would
be a dreadful idea.
Think of what you'd get.
[LAUGHING]
I mean, only Minister of Culture
that any of us can imagine
would be ourselves.
You know?
We would all, on
a certain level,
like to be the
Minister de la Couture.
But it ain't going to happen.
And if it did happen,
it would be somebody
who would be sort of just--
you know, would turn
it into a nightmare.
Don't forget-- I mean,
it would become such a--
the way in which the NEA
became a partisan football
over the last few
years I promise
you would be nothing compared
to the results of having
a Minister of Culture
in this democracy.
I don't believe you see
that actually it works out--
I don't think it's
altogether consistent
with the democratic
spirit of America, which
we foreigners so much admire.
I mean, I really wouldn't want
to see an American Jack Lang.
And Jack Lang, in
a certain sense,
was the American Jack Lang.
[LAUGHING]
Sir?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
My name is Jim-- just a person.
I grew up outside of Boston
in a sort of suburban town.
HUGHES: Me too.
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering, not only
in short-term, how they
should be administered,
or how public support should
be directed to long-term?
You know, it's only
the last 30 years
that the NEA has even existed.
More to the point is whether
we should have any at all.
HUGHES: Sorry.
Whether we should have
any at all of what?
AUDIENCE: Public support.
HUGHES: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yes?
HUGHES: Yeah.
It's always been a subject
of very divisive debate
in America, whether
you should have it.
AUDIENCE: You know, I think
about it in my suburban town,
when public funds for
schooling and education
started to dry up--
HUGHES: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --one of the
first things people
think that is disposable
is art class or art space.
HUGHES: Unfortunately, yes.
AUDIENCE: It just
makes me think--
it makes me wonder how
much basic interest America
as a culture has in art.
Is that any lower than
it is in other place?
What is your opinion about what
our fundamental basic interest
is in this?
HUGHES: See, I
think, for instance,
that art classes in schools can
have a very powerful educative
effect.
You know, they can be
terrific for the kids,
and not just because it's
teaching a finger-painting,
but because it connects them
to a whole mode of experiencing
the world which they
would not have otherwise.
And the idea that, in some way,
classes which expose the kids
to painting, music, dance,
whatever it might be, theatre,
is in some way optional, I
think it's a tremendous pity.
Looking back on
my own education,
which was certainly a very much
more classical and rigorous--
I wouldn't say anti-art, but it
just ignored the plastic arts
completely, I might say.
But you know there was--
the school did put on its plays.
And I learned more from
being in those plays than I--
probably in the end, it was
useful to me in later life
than I did from--
I'm sorry to say
this, because I wasn't
very good at ancient
Greek, but possibly more
than I did from
studying ancient Greek.
But there is always a tendency,
and it's true in Australia too,
and it's true in England,
as well as in America.
Americans are not
sort of isolated--
some bunch of 260
million isolated
Philistines in this regard.
They're all over the world, to
regard the sphere of the arts
as being in some way
somewhat optional.
It's the icing on the cake.
You know, it's the meringue,
but the real cake is the sponge,
and that's underneath.
I believe in a much more
organically knit kind
of conception of cultural
activity than that.
But I'm sorry one
of the first things
is to go in the small term
when cuts have to be made
is the supposedly less
important art classes.
But that is just something that,
you know, one is dealing with,
and it's the same all over the
world in moments of shrinking
educational possibility.
You know?
The visual literacy
of Americans,
you know, many
Americans compared
to that of the almost
complete visual indifference
of many French that I
know, is staggering.
But you know, it's always
going to seem somehow optional.
And this was one of
the situations which
the NEA was set up to solve.
And on the whole, I
think with the usual,
with all the admitted sort
of losses and imperfections,
you know, and outright waste
of money, and confusions,
and controversies, it has on the
whole worked out pretty well.
There.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
My name is Ellen Parker, and I'm
the co-author of "The National
Endowment for the Arts
Summary Report on the National
Choreographers Study" coming
out later this summer.
In hearing the report on
[INAUDIBLE] processes, in 1965,
choreographers were
the first artist group
funded by the Endowment.
And they selected
seven choreographers,
including the grand Alvin Ailey,
Merce Cunningham, José Limon.
Now, anyone who considers
himself or herself to be
a choreographer and has a
modicum of writing ability
can apply to the Endowment.
HUGHES: I'm sorry.
Anybody who considers--
AUDIENCE: --who has a
modicum of writing ability.
One has to be able to write--
HUGHES: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --in order
to have one's talent
considered by the Endowment.
My question is, what do we
do about the pool of artists
who are either so disaffected or
disinterested that they're not
going to make applications to
any funding agency who do have
talent, who are out there?
How do we find today's
talent in America?
Do we rely upon mere ability
to write the case of their art?
HUGHES: Yes.
Because if they
don't approach you,
how can we know about them?
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
But if they can't write,
or don't write, or won't
write, how do we find those?
HUGHES: I don't know many
artists who can't write.
I mean, I suppose
such may exist.
The point is not that you find
them, but that they find you.
I mean, the NEA is out there.
Everybody knows it exists.
And if the artist does not
wish to apply for an NEA grant,
that is that artist's
absolute right,
as well as it is his
or her right to apply.
The NEA is not a
missionary institution.
It's one which responds
to applications,
as I understand it.
But perhaps you feel
it should be a more
missionary institution.
AUDIENCE: I feel convinced
that there is talent in America
which is not known, and--
HUGHES: That is
true of all times.
AUDIENCE: Artists that are more
busy struggling to survive,
to create their art, whether
it's dance, or music,
or theatre, not all of them
have the time nor the expertise.
They're not born with
a god-given ability
to write a grant application
and make a persuasive argument.
HUGHES: Well, in
that case, perhaps
you should streamline
and simplify
the process of
grant application.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm sorry.
I can suggest no
other alternative.
AUDIENCE: I just
wanted to know how
you would force the cream
to the top to suggest--
HUGHES: You can't force
the cream to the top.
The cream has to float of
its own molecular nature.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm Catherine Shu.
I'm acting director of Chinese
Culture and Collection.
The purpose of our
organization is
to fulfill the needs of
American majority society needs,
which we have a tremendous
need to understand
the other side of the
world, and that we
as a small group,
concerned citizens, most
are immigrants from China,
Taiwan, or Hong Kong.
We took an initiative to be
a self-support organization
and to provide [INAUDIBLE]
workshops coinciding
with school education,
mostly elementary school,
middle school, and high school.
My question is, as national
federal support organization,
how do we support the initiative
adverse to an organization
like us.
So far, I, myself, and
several board members
have called upon National
Endowment for Arts.
HUGHES: With any success?
AUDIENCE: I'm very sorry
to say that no success.
They have suggest us to
provide coupons for scholars,
for professors, for
their study groups.
However, the federal
funding doesn't
go to the common elementary,
high schools now.
I'm very puzzled.
HUGHES: You see,
unfortunately, I
can't help you, because
I do not know anything--
I'm a journalist, and I've never
applied for a grant in my life.
And so I don't know what the
procedure is for application
to, you know, foundations.
AUDIENCE: They say they
don't have a category
to fit into our needs.
HUGHES: Well, in that case--
wouldn't it possibly fall under
the purview of the National
Endowment of the Humanities?
I just don't know.
I'm sorry.
I can't [INAUDIBLE].
I can't answer the question.
AUDIENCE: I'm glad you say
you don't know because that's
the reason I, myself,
and my colleagues
come to this convention.
Hopefully we have
better luck next time.
HUGHES: I think
probably if you were
to ask somebody who actually
works within the NEA
and works within
funding organizations,
you might very well get an
answer to that question.
But I myself cannot supply that.
HARRIS: Also, this
is the last one.
HUGHES: OK.
This is the last one.
Sir?
AUDIENCE: My name
is George Bennett,
and I'm a student
in Boston here.
I have a question.
You pointed out that
the relative value
of NEA funding in seven
days was higher than it
has been in any time since?
HUGHES: Well, the actual value
of watching it for your dollar.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Exactly.
It's my understanding
that during the '70s,
the NEA funded relatively safe
forms of art and symphonies
and dance companies.
I'm wondering if you feel that
half the reason it exists now
is necessarily non-political,
or whether it may possibly
be an inevitable result of
the more challenging work
that the NEA has funded
in the last few years?
HUGHES: Well, I think
that, certainly,
the NEA has come under
fire because some of the--
I mean, obviously,
it's come under fire
because some of the
material that it's funded
has been found morally
offensive by others.
That we take for granted.
And I think that if you were to
look through the, as it were,
the funding annals
of the NEA, you
would find that only a
small number of grants,
and most of those, in fact, in
the 1980s rather than the '70s,
caused any kind of
kerfuffle at all.
It does not-- you see, I have
to say that I'm rather opposed
to this conventionalized
language of saying
that things like symphony
concerts, and dance,
and so on, and so
forth are safe culture.
I mean, first of all, what
sort of value, I suppose,
to attach relatively to
safe and unsafe culture.
I mean, it seems to me
that the performance
of say, a piece of music
by Hindemith, or Mozart,
or whoever, the
results of it are
not to be classified in terms
of either safety or unsafety,
but rather in terms of the
sort of aesthetic pleasure
and enlightenment that the
audience might get from them.
I mean the idea that the NEA has
to be strung out between works
of art which are--
well, nobody uses the
word avant garde anymore,
but cutting edge and
those which are not,
and that it should be
supporting cutting edge stuff
and shouldn't be
supporting the other,
I think basically that's hokum.
Because value does not
rise from anywhere else
except deep inside
the work of art.
It doesn't rise primarily
from its supposed power
of social contestation,
although that may have something
to do with it.
It isn't the mandate of
the NEA to constantly fund
works of which will
notionally at all points
challenge the status quo.
The status quo in America
is enormously tolerant.
The status quo is, you know,
if you're talking about taste,
includes just about
everything and its opposite.
It is a big rubber wall,
which it is really hard
to make a permanent dent
in, because America's
institutional culture
for the last 70 years
has been nothing
other than the new.
Therefore, this is
why I keep saying
that what the NEA ought to be
going for is art which is, sort
of trying to encourage works
of art rather upon the guesses
it can make about
their aesthetic quality
than their capacity for
social contestation.
Now you can have very
good works of art,
you can have great works of art,
that are socially challenging.
Of course you can.
Always have had.
But the idea that the NEA should
be looking out specifically
for works of art which are,
for instance, political rather
than nonpolitical, I
think, is something
of a distortion of its mission.
No, I'm not going
to get off on this
because I've said it before.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HUGHES: Yeah, go ahead.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HUGHES: Well, I think the
NEA was poleaxed by what
went on in the late '80s.
It wasn't expecting it.
It didn't know how
to deal with it,
and it proved remarkably
inept at responding to it.
And of course, you
know, there was
a sense of disorientation and
loss of direction and loss
of mission.
This, I think,
combined with the fact
that the man who was running
it at the time, Frohnmeyer,
was not the captain one would
wanted to have on the ship when
the typhoon hit.
Sure, I mean the NEA has got
a lot of ground to make up.
I mean, the NEA
has got to go back
to being a pretty
tough organization.
Otherwise, it's
going to go down.
AUDIENCE: My names
is [? Hal Tobich, ?]
and I'm [INAUDIBLE].
Would you be interested
in heading up the NEA?
HUGHES: No.
Here I am, late in middle
age, not a citizen.
I mean, do you
think that I'd want
to spend the rest of
my life butting horns
with this bunch of
dinosaurs and madmen?
AUDIENCE: Well, I reckon
it's sort of jail.
HUGHES: Yeah, right.
[LAUGHING]
This is a job which nobody
in his right mind who
wants to write or paint
or do anything himself
would want to do that.
AUDIENCE: We need
a tough cookie.
HUGHES: You need a tough cookie.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have anybody in mind?
Can you think of anybody?
HUGHES: I mean, my candidate for
the NEA would be John Brademas,
but he can't do it.
He doesn't want to do it.
I mean, I would really
like to see-- you know,
Brademas would be
superb in that job.
But it's a very tough job,
and the rewards for it
are not actually very high.
You know, it's there
a problem-- you create
one ingrate and 20 malcontents.
OK, thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHING]
HARRIS: Thank you
very much for coming.
I daresay that not
all of our panelists
would have agreed
with everything
that was said tonight,
and I did resist
the urge, a sort of professorial
urge, to call on them
and say, Mr. Hansel, what
do you think of that?
HUGHES: Manana.
HARRIS: But you will hear
tomorrow if you come.
I hope you will all be there.
And it does begin at 9:15.
I look forward to seeing you.
Thank you, and thank
you, Robert Hughes.